mike built a rectangular dog pen that is
21 feet long and has a perimeter of 78
feet
what is the width of mike's dog pen
so let's draw what it might look like so
it might look something like this
do my best to draw it a rectangular
potential dog pen
so let's say that this is the dog pen
right over here and they give us its
length its length is 21 feet
its length is 21 feet so this
distance right over here is 21 feet and
of course if that distance is 21 feet
this distance is also this distance is
also going to be 21 feet now they also
tell us that the perimeter is 78 feet
so the perimeter is 78 feet
78 feet so we need to figure out the
width and the width would be
the width would be this length or this
width i should say
this width which is going to be the same
thing as that width right over here
so let's think about and we know how we
figure out the perimeter if we added
this distance 21 feet to this distance
the width plus 21 feet to the width
again we're going to get to 78 feet so
one way to back into what the width is
is to say well look if we sum up all of
these lengths we're going to get 28 feet
so let's at least subtract these two
orange lengths the 221 feet from the 78
feet and then we figure out how much
length essentially these two widths have
to make up so let's subtract
let's do 78 minus 21
minus 21 and what's that going to be
equal to so that's 78
minus 42
and 78 minus 42. i want to make a
careless mistake 78 minus 42 is going to
get me to 36.
so this is equal to 36 and let's remind
ourselves what 36 is what 36 feet is
that's the total length or i should say
the total width if we were to take the
width down here and add it to the width
up here
now we know something else these are the
exact same width that this distance is
the same as this distance and if we add
them together we get to 36. so what are
two distances or what are two numbers
that i can add together to get to 36
well we know that 18 plus 18 we know
that
plus 18 is equal to
36. so this one down here must be 18 and
this one up here must also be 18. and we
can verify that try adding all of these
up together you add the two widths you
get 18 plus 18 and you add the two
lengths plus 21
plus 21 and you are left with
36 which is exactly what we got here
this is what we needed the two widths to
add up to plus 42
plus 42
which is of course equal to 36 plus 42
is equal to 78 which is the perimeter